[Music]
good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson said here's an interesting story
if the New Yorker was still a real
magazine they might write it up but of
course they won't here it is last summer
deep in the bowels of the transportation
department in Washington some nameless
Federal analysts came across a highly
puzzling Trend in a pile of stats on
traffic deaths
it turned out that in the year 2020 the
number of American motorists who died on
the road spiked dramatically traffic
deaths Rose by more than 10 percent in a
single year now in any year that would
be odd and distressing but coming as it
did in 2020 it was flat out bizarre
because as you'll remember in 2020 there
was a pandemic it had just started
millions of people stayed home that year
they did not drive to work many didn't
drive at all in 2020 roads were less
crowded than they had been in decades in
this country so of course you would
expect far fewer traffic deaths less
traffic fewer people dying in traffic
and yet there were more traffic deaths I
think that's weird it gets weirder if
you look deeper into the numbers you saw
that not only were more Americans dying
in cars in the year 2020 a staggering
number of those who died were black
traffic deaths among African Americans
Rose by nearly 25 percent in a single
year
that's unprecedented so in a normal
presidential Administration that
question why is this happening would be
the subject of urgent academic study
people are dying let's figure out why
but in this Administration it was not
the subject of Virgin academic study why
because Pete put a judge is now the
Secretary of Transportation but a judge
once worked at McKinsey so he already
knew the cause of these deaths and it
was needless to say racism racism did it
because America's roads are racist
they're killing black people as the
Washington Post put at the
transportation department quote
concluded that black communities tend to
be crisscrossed by more dangerous roads
end quote
now that made sense to The Washington
Post and you can see why civil engineers
road builders bent on genocide wood
needles to say put all the dangerous
roads in black neighborhoods that's who
they are and that kind of thing happens
all the time in America this is a racist
Country Joe Biden has told us that
countless times
but what doesn't make sense is the
timing here very few of these racist
roads are new most of them had been
there a long time
so why did so many black motorists
suddenly start dying in the year 2020.
Pete but a judge had no idea he didn't
even bother to guess because honestly he
didn't really care
but we do care we've got a theory and
here it is if you look at the numbers
you will notice the traffic deaths among
African Americans in the year 2020
surged in the month of June fatalities
among black drivers in June 2020 were
fully 55 percent higher than they were
in June of 2019.
you never see increases like that what
could have happened
well let's see it was in the last week
of May of 2020 that a convicted felon
called George Floyd died in police
custody in Minneapolis and after that
you'll recall everything changed what
changed most of all was how we regarded
the rule of law
as Russ Martin of the Governor's Highway
Safety Association put it Floyd's death
quote accelerated National discussion
about equity in transportation and that
discussion would include quote questions
about enforcement oh there it is right
there that's the answer cops across the
country were told to stop enforcing
traffic laws against black drivers no
one wanted to be accused of arresting
somebody for the crime of quote driving
while black
so in the name of equity the law no
longer applied to huge numbers of people
result
thousands of Americans died
this is a trend you may have noticed and
it doesn't just apply to traffic and it
doesn't just cause traffic deaths
here's a chart that shows the number of
black Americans murdered every year from
2010 to 2020.
look carefully and you notice two major
spikes one Spike came in 2014 that was
exactly the moment the media decided to
lie to us about the death of Michael
Brown in Ferguson Missouri
activists then used that false story to
drive police out of black neighborhoods
in many parts of America that was
supposed to make things better fewer
cops less racism right no
in that effect a lot of people got
killed and most of them were black
then there's the second spike in the
last decade the biggest one yet as we
said it came in the summer of 2020 and
it's continuing today
same reason same effect
there aren't a lot of Trends in social
science that can be explained in a
single graph but this is one of them
less law enforcement means more crime
and over time it means more dead
children more grieving parents you don't
need to be a criminologist to understand
this it's very obvious even Lori
Lightfoot gets it Lori Lightfoot is the
mayor of Chicago thanks to her
equity-based policies the city of
Chicago is falling apart people are
dying in huge numbers shootings in
Chicago jump 60 percent last year Lori
Lightfoot knows perfectly well this is
happening she knows why it is happening
but Lori Lightfoot doesn't care Lori
Lightfoot is so uninterested in all of
those deaths mostly of black people that
she won't even answer questions about
them when asked watch this exchange it
comes from Tuesday of this week
every time you have a press conference
you say crime is down uh the economy is
booming well that's not that's not true
but get your questions sir across the
street we had a police officer on duty
the victim of a hit and run
we have Michigan Avenue the Magnificent
miles now referred to as the mile of
fear the Water Tower Place has thrown
the keys back to the lender they say
they don't want to be in Chicago anymore
real Chicagoans are asking me how could
you possibly even consider
running for reelection as mayor of the
city of Chicago after all the harm
you've caused well I disagree with you
fundamentally
um and I don't think I need to address
any and dignify your comments one second
further next question
next question
so Lori Lightfoot won't answer the
question precisely because she knows the
answer in the name of equity officials
in Chicago have stopped enforcing the
law and not some esoteric tax law that
no one really understands the basic laws
like you can't hurt other people
they're releasing criminals who go on to
murder more citizens this is the Triumph
of ideology over human life here's just
one example that comes from Fox's
Chicago station
the details on the offender's prior
history does call into question how he
was released this document from the Cook
County State's Attorney's Office says in
June of 2021 sixteen-year-old Anthony
Brown LED police on a foot chase that's
when they recovered a loaded 22 caliber
Glock handgun with an extended magazine
five days later he was released on
electronic monitoring 14 days later the
bracelet came off and he was put on a
curfew six months later they say he was
involved in a carjacking this time
police recovered a loaded Glock nine
millimeter handgun with a round in the
chamber that's when he was put back on
monetary in the case of Tuesday's
shooting the 16 year old is charged with
first-degree murder and carjacking he
carjacked a Lyft driver earlier in the
day and took off in that same Infinity
after the alleged shooting of a teen he
didn't even know
stories like this constantly in the city
of Chicago cities across the country
they're always the same but the details
of this one tell you everything a
criminal runs from the police carrying
an illegal gun then the same politicians
who never stop lecturing you about gun
control it's immoral to defend yourself
they scream at you those same people let
this guy who used a gun to commit a
crime out of jail immediately because
equity
then he gets rid of his ankle monitor
and commits a carjacking then what
happens
well Lori lightfoot's friends release
him once again because incarceration bad
so what does he do he drives off to
shoot and kill a 15 year old because why
wouldn't he there's no penalty
now if tragedies like this happened
occasionally you would call them
accidents you would feel sad but you
wouldn't be bothered these are not
accidents this is happening every day in
the city of Chicago
fully 43 percent of all criminals
convicted in the state of Illinois
commit new crimes within three years of
being released and some are released
very early that's a high number
compared to other states in saner places
like Texas South Carolina West Virginia
the recidivism rate after three years is
about half of that what's the difference
politics honestly that's not a partisan
talking point it's true for the last
decade for example the most liberal
state in the country California has
recorded a recidivism rate of nearly 50
percent now keep in mind the irony here
they tell you that we shouldn't
incarcerate people because incarceration
doesn't work and if you really want to
rehabilitate people you have to let them
out
but they're not rehabilitated that's why
they're reoffending and almost 50
percent in the state of California so
incarceration has two purposes one
is to improve the prisoner so he won't
reoffend but the main purpose is to
protect the rest of us who aren't
committing crimes who've got kids who
just want to live a normal life they've
forgotten that part
so every day in California politicians
release truly dangerous criminals back
into the public sphere and this is why
you're now taking a very big risk if you
dare to use public transportation in the
city of Los Angeles you could be shot or
sexually assaulted and we're not
guessing we have the tape
here's surveillance footage from LA's
transit system it's on your screen right
now it includes pictures of a woman
being raped in public as she's sitting
down we're cutting some of it out that
happened in public
and it happens a lot that kind of thing
so we went to LA for the premiere of
season two of our documentary series we
went there because we wanted to
understand how one man A Man Called
George gascon a prosecutor backed by
George Soros could have done so much in
such little time to destroy the city and
of course he did in the name of equity
we talked to the family of a murder
victim called Fatima Johnson it was a
bracing conversation
Pima Johnson a mother of six was found
brutally murdered in her apartment she
was violently murdered beaten to death
hot tight and gagged
the suspect is a career criminal called
Daryl Collins served decades in prison
for two murders as well as a string of
armed robberies he had quite an
extensive criminal history a series of
armed robberies he killed two different
people on two separate occasions he was
under 25 when he committed those murders
he was eligible for youth full parole
and the parole board decided oh it looks
like you know you've rehabilitated
yourself and we'll go ahead and release
you that was a huge mistake you know he
came in and told my mom he was going to
marry her and you know it would be our
step dad
Prince Charming Bush despite previous
convictions for murder and despite the
fact that Fatima Johnson was bound and
horrifyingly tortured before she was
killed killed George cascone is refusing
to add any enhancements to this case
George cascone is not the only corrupt
prosecutor is doing this George Soros
has paid for people just like George
cascone in many American cities Kim Fox
in Chicago Larry craster in Philadelphia
Alvin Bragg now in Manhattan others in
every case many Americans thousands
overall have died as a result
so who's benefiting from this Slaughter
and how exactly are they benefiting
that's a fair question you've got to
wonder we do know for certain that
voters don't want it Americans want the
laws they voted for to be enforced and
that is true of black voters just like
any others because why wouldn't it be
sorry white liberals black people don't
love crime actually you're not helping
black people by increasing the amount of
crime in their neighborhoods and a new
Pew poll proves this the poll asked
black adults what they cared about most
and guess what it wasn't racism and
diversity or Equity that was near the
bottom of the list what they cared about
most was quote violence and crime that's
what they cared about why wouldn't they
care about it
so as people to judge Frets about racist
roads thousands of black people are
dying of gunshot wounds
normal people are sick of this in San
Francisco The Lunatic Equity mongering
D.A there Chessa Boudin is facing a
recall which could succeed boudini has
among other things encouraged open-air
narcotics markets throughout the city of
San Francisco and as a result you
guessed it more than twice as many
people have died from drug od's in San
Francisco than from covid
who could support something like that
you'd have to be pretty out of touch
well singer John Legend does quote I
endorse Chessa for D.A when he ran for
election Legend tweeted and I support
him now of course you do John Legend the
by administration supports him too just
days ago police in Washington raided an
apartment where they found a dog called
Pablo the dog had been stolen a gunpoint
by thieves who also took drugs and money
at gunpoint so police arrested four men
three juveniles in the apartment a few
hours later Joe Biden's justice
department announced he was refusing to
charge any of them
the U.S attorney's office has decided
not to move forward with what they were
charged with and also confirmed that the
four adults that were arrested have been
released I can tell you the seven people
arrested yesterday were charged with
receiving stolen property so receiving
Pablo in this case Pablo was one of two
dogs stolen during a Wednesday violent
crime spree that police say lasted
nearly an hour there were four incidents
reported within that time frame
including a double shooting in Northeast
D.C along with the armed robberies of
two dog owners police tell us that when
they recovered Pablo in a Northeast DC
apartment that they also took
apprehended some items here including
drugs a pistol an AR-15 style rifle and
ammunition
so what happens when you allow people to
commit violence the one thing the state
can never do the state is a monopoly on
violence in a democracy we decide when
violence is appropriate but what happens
when you allow anti-social elements to
commit all the violence they want
you get a lot of violence and your
cities start to resemble third world
hellholes people are executed in broad
daylight and no one bothers to call the
cops that just happened in Atlanta
it's 51 year old security guard Anthony
Frazier getting out of his vehicle on
Monday near Cleveland Avenue in
southwest Atlanta
little does Fraser know he's about to be
murdered
now watch as the suspected gunman walks
toward him with a pistol in his right
hand another man sitting there in the
curb will watch the whole thing happen
police don't show the actual shooting
just the aftermath Frazier laying there
on the ground dead his bloodied body has
been blurred
the alleged gunman goes through his
belongings before casually walking away
from the scene remarkably the witness
who was sitting at the corner gets up
and walks by Frasier's lifeless body
just shaking his head in apparent
disbelief then two other men approached
the victim and also appear to search him
take a closer look we've zoomed in on
the video as they then walk away with
what appears to be the deceased victim's
wallet
there's something really wrong with
everyone in that video except the dead
man there's something really wrong with
the rest of us for putting up with this
and not figuring out why exactly it's
happening it's a little more complicated
than racism and mass incarceration
something really dark is going on but we
can say that these sorts of things
happen a lot more than they otherwise
would when you decide that law should be
applied on the basis of skin color when
you decide that a lot of people die they
bleed out in gutters on city streets as
the rest of the neighborhood hides in
doors in Terror and as it happens most
of the Dead come from the very group our
leaders say they're protecting we love
you so much for letting you die
that's the equity agenda too bad BLM
never told us how it was going to end
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight